hello darling it's always nice when we  get to spend time together  do your job and hand me the trophy let's  rap now  boston is jumping states going crazy  greatest duo ever belichick and brady no  speculation no more surprises letting  you know who the greatest franchise  is crowd celebrating there's a party in  the stands got bacardi in my hand  plucking body in my hand goddale tried  to stop us but he couldn't drop us spain  with the falcons they're not us we never  lied you can't deny this just found out  what the greatest franchises  [Music]  football and rap music greatest since  lovati and no one can dispute it known  for my coaching and known for my  slimeness bill belichick from the  greatest franchise [ __ ] my name's tom  brady and i'm the next singer i've won  the ball so many times i'll run it out  of fingers i'd like to thank gisele and  the reps for making calls in the  commissioner for caring about his  deflated balls